حتى بخير وبذلك كبير مستشاري رئيس
الاوكرانيه فروض ديماريزيرانسكي حتى حلفاء
بلاده على التفكير بشكل اسرع في زياده دعم
هذا العسكري غدتا عدم توصل توصلهم الى
اجماعا يتم بموجبه ارسال الدبابات الثقيله
الى كاف في ظل تحفظ برلين حيه لتسليم
دبابات اليوبار الثقيله الى اوكرانيا
خالد
لماذا فشل اجتماع انا اينشتاين في اقناع
المانيا تسليم هذه الدبابات اليوبارد
الثاني همم
حتى تكون الامور واضحه المانيه لا ترفض
السماح بتسليم الدبابه اثنان الى الجانب
الاوكراني لكن هي توافق على المبدا لكن
تختلف في التفاصيل هي تريد ان يكون معها
دبابه اخرى وتحديدا دبابه امريكيه ابرامز
واحد اهم دبابه امريكيه تريد ان تكون مع
هذه الدبابه لماذا من المفرد من حلف
الاطلسي وبالتالي ان كان هناك ردت فعل
روسيه على المانيا لانها ارسل الدبابات
حلف الاطلس يتدخل ربما هذا لا يقنع
المانيا بما فيه الكفايه رسميا لا يوجد
تفسير رسمي الماني لماذا تشترط المانيا
همم ارسال دبابه امريكيه مع بابا
الالمانيه حتى ان بعض المسؤولين حاولوا
التعرض من هذا الربط لكن عديد من المصادر
اجمعت على ان الشرط الالماني هو ان تكون
الولايات المتحده حاضره في الموضوع بعض
المسؤولين الغربيين الذين رفضوا الكشف عن
اسمائهم قالوا ان الموضوع تاريخي الالمان
لا يريدون ان تكون هناك دبابه المانيه
موجوده في حرب وبالقرب من الحدود الروسيه
حتى لا يذكر الروس بالهجوم النازي على
الحدود الروسيه لا اعتقد ان هذا هو السبب
الحقيقي لانه من ارسل الامريكيون دباباتهم
المان سالونيون ستكون قريبا بالحدود
الروسيه اذا هذا هو ليس في تقرير سبب
الرئيسي لكن السبب الرئيسي ربما هو الرغبه
في نوع من الحمايه بمعنى ان همم ارسل
الدبابات غربيه لتقاتل الروس على الارض
الاوكرانيه همم الروسيا ينظرون من الذي
ارسل الدبابات ان كانت المانيا قد يكون
هناك رد فعل ضد المانيا لكن سنه الولايات
المتحده والمانيا وبريطانيا الروس ينظرون
اولا الولايات المتحده وقد يغير من موقفهم
السؤال حقيقه الذي يشغل ال ال ال ال
الازهار ربما عند البعض ان كان الشرط
الالماني هو ان ترسل الولايات المتحده
دباباتيه الى هناك لماذا لم ترسل لماذا لا
توافق الولايات المتحده وهي تدعم بشكل هي
اهم دوله داعمه لاوكرانيا رسميا
الامريكيون يقولون الدبابات الامريكيه غير
مفيده هي صعبه الصيانه ومكلفه لن تكون
مفيده كذبابات الالمانيه القريبه
الجغرافيا والموجود منها نحو الفي اي قطعه
في دول اوروبيه عديده يمكن ان تسمح
المانيا بارسالهم وقطع الغيار المتوفره
وهي اسهل في الصيانه وكل ذلك وبالتالي
الدبابات الامريكيه ستكون اكثر تعقيدا
هناك من يشكك حقيقه في هذه الروايه ان
يكون هذا هو السبب الحقيقي وقد يكون نحن
هنا في اطار ترجيحات ليست معلومات قد يكون
السبب الامريكي هو الخشيه من مواجهه سلاح
امريكي مدببه امريكيه لدبابه روسيه اولا
هو اختبار ثانيا غير انه اختبار ان وقع
الدبابه امريكيه في يد الروس ويعني انتقال
التكنولوجيا الامريكيه ايضا الى يد الروس
قد يكون هذا من احد الاسباب شكرا لك خالد
الغراب لي على هذه القراءه شكرا لك